salut à tous aujourd'hui petite partie
de pêche au bord du canal du midi mais
avant ça on a un jeu concours à vous
proposer
donc ce jeu concours qui organisait en
partenariat avec maison de la détection
qui nous ont fourni ce magnifique aimant
360° terror donc regardez moi cette
beauté un petit peu magnifiquement avec
sa protection à aimants magnetar les
meilleures du marché
donc voilà avec ça les trouvailles sont
assurés
ouais c'est un très bon élément pour
tout ce qui est canal avec la vase
y'a pas de problème ça va tout choper à
360 degrés mais aussi utilisable en
rivière sans souci cdm en costaud dans
leur coque a aucun problème ceux qui
disent que c'est fragile c'est pas le
cas je pêche avec un 360 depuis un an
maintenant il est nickel
voilà donc pour participer il suffit de
commenter la vidéo avec ce que vous
voulez donc une petite citation comme
vous voulez un petit mot tout ce que
vous voulez et laïque est aussi ça fait
plaisir lee quéval attention à vous s'il
ya plus de commentaires que de like et
encore une fois merci à maison d'être
des sections de voie là ils nous ont
fourni non seulement les membres mais
aussi le kit complet avec la corde de 20
mètres et avec la protection pour les
mois donc on laisse à peu près cinq
jours avant qui voilà vous avez cinq
jours pour participer donc ça fait que
vous pouvez participer jusqu'au voilà
voilà
et sinon ben on vous laisse apprécier la
pêche et bon courage pour le jeu
concours
un train qui sera réalisée en présence
d'un huissier de justice c'est ça et
tout de suite la pêche
regardez moi ce spot aujourd'hui c'est
parfait c'est parfait c'est sûrement
déjà fait aussi mais il reste toujours
des choses en attaque tout de suite le
ponton ça peut être très intéressant
parce que les péniches sari titien
n'attend que les clues s'ouvre donc y
elle s'arrêterait souvent juste faut
faire attention encore une fois au bord
en métal mais normalement il peut y
avoir plein de pièces d'outils de
couverts
voyons voir ce qu'on a trouvé dans un
ballet et une petite fourchette du
couvert j'avais annoncé une petite
fourchette
je suis juste sous le pont et il ya
quelque chose et qui fait son poids à
ben levier une manivelle des cluses en
un grand classique
on va voir ce cas d'autres sous ce pont
moi j'aimerais bien voir s'ils ont jeté
un coffre fort parce que s'il y en a un
il est pas loin
il sera dessous à pierre pas mal quoi ah
bah oui si aura droit à quelque chose
assez lourd oh c'est quoi ça on y attend
c'est un gros mois c'est pas voir tout
ça waouh regard ce marteau il est non et
bouts de verre à dents ça je sais pas ce
que c'est
et un ou plusieurs trucs encore c'est
bien lourd c'est quoi ça
ça c'est pas les fusées éclairantes de
bateaux sa wii fait main rouge c'est des
fusées de détresse de bateaux et moi
avec ça j'ai eu ou la séquence a atteint
1 c'est un bouchon de réservoir froid
donc ça et c'est trop long c gepa c'est
hyper l'on puisse déclarer c'est
possible que ça résiste à l'eau st
ouais je sais pas ça s'est quand même
fait pour être dans les bateaux donc
ouais peut-être pas si longtemps c'est
ce que c'est et les francs waouh
un français un français
pas mal non je pense que simplement
c'est nettoyer de temps en temps cette
portion est là on shoppe tout ce qui est
dans la vase ou voilà ils nettoient pas
tous à chaque fois une clochette de vélo
ou un truc comme ça a dit russell et à
manger quelque chose
enfin boules de pétanque ouais je crois
à la taille
oui
elle et des biens
bah au poids c'est cross chose de gros 5
kg hab et encore non donne à nivelles
des cluses en un coup énorme encore du
poids au sein l'antivol ça je crois
ouais ouais c'est un vieil antivol
[Applaudissements]
tu vas faire part aux poissons tiens
c'est l'intention qui compte
hassan pied de parasol très applaudi par
tout ça a été filmé on entreprend pour
un nouveau franc juste après donc on va
on peut tout est beau
c'est parti pour le premier lancer ça
fait bizarre j'ai l'impression d'être au
même point c'est exactement les mêmes où
c'est propre c'est très propre
oh c'est quoi ça une pièce pièce ça doit
du franc franc de 1970 croit que ses
contours là même où un franc de 1970 non
ouais
ouais c'est bizarre ah ça c'est bien on
regarde ces quotas si vous savez dans
les commentaires un outil mais c'est
bizarre ce serait pas un truc de grenade
regard une goupille pas plus qu'une
copie alors ouais c'est bizarre mais
c'est bien une grenade d'entraînement
lacrymo wendy elle est là ouais ouais
c'est chez toi ouais enfin pas bonnes
notes de guerre tu vois mais à ça fait
penser à des coups pieds non pas oui
avait pas dégoupillé je suis pas c'est
pas un tournevis en garde robe
ouais bon c'est cool on trouve des
choses moi aussi ça on fait du bien
d'avoir way or j'ai fait le même sur le
pont ah oui ça gagne est apte à gagner
mais bon il est mort d'un feu de bois
bagages et du poids en direct
procès du procès du bois et les gros
mois au parasol c'est un faux cul mettre
vos qui m'aide c'est plein d'eau et de
merde un podcast très vite et non mais
il est mort je mets de côté
vas-y vide le nickel et encore et encore
tautavel pied à la fermeture
reconnaît-on par la salle ouais on lui
rend ouais
[Musique]
voilà où est par contre b en vrai le
tout blanc ce qui irait pas assez
dommage non il est bon et vous c'est
cool nickel bon mais on continue donc là
je me suis accroché dessus donc c'est
peut-être le pied du parasol c est lourd
un passé pas inquiète parasols c'est
trop long ou alors fassiez oui j'ai un
morceau croit tout mais du coup c'était
h est sûre ça lâche sa bulle impression
on va tirer progressivement
ça vient
ça aura besoin des doux ce film
à voir l'état falloir 30 et pour la
nettoyer
pourquoi telle autre c'est rempli de
mousse je sens quelque chose ou pas très
gros mais est bien quelque chose ou là
honnêtement haut niveau c'est génial son
corps est la plus ferme et mon [ __ ] il
a acheté la corde avec aulas a bien la
preuve que ça a été fait oui mais là
mais la preuve aussi cet effet des
éléments assez nul pour tous ceux qui
n'ont pas le temps d'attendre la fin du
jeu concours
je vous propose de faire un tour en
descriptions il ya un lien vers le site
de maisons de la détection qui propose
tout un tas de matériel et les meilleurs
éléments du marché bongo nickel je
prends mais là quand elle a l'air pas
trop mal quand d'escapades bombe en
nickel
bon les amis cette vidéo touche à sa fin
j'espère que vous avez apprécié nos
trouvailles nous c'était une partie de
plaisir mais il a fait très froid et la
faim commence à tous à dire le droit
ouais si vous reconnaissez votre élan au
foot garde au chaud
il vous sera restitué même si voilà
c'est simple au passé c'est pas très
efficace
pour la pêche aliments
allez voilà c'est bien
ouais on est en bas aussi j'ai accord
offrira dans le sol avec elle un truc un
peu intéressants présentée main arts a
assez froid 1 ces glaces s'il veut faire
de mai doit vraiment agacer aller